so if you can tell a story for 45
minutes and hold somebody I think you
have a movie and if you're not quite
sure invite somebody for coffee or a
drink and when you tell it to people you
say let me buy you a drink let me get
your coffee and let me tell you a story
and each time you tell it you're not
really interested in whether the person
likes your idea what you really care
about is the body language do you own
them and you try to judge people's
response to it and you can tell if you
own them you can tell it in their eyes
you can tell it in their restlessness
and if you own them you own them and if
you don't you have to come up with
something and then toward the end of it
get to a certain Junction get up go to
the bathroom and come back and start
another conversation if they don't ask
you what happened to that story you
don't have a story